you famously worked in publishing oh yes
I did yes a little while what did you do
we in publishing I have no idea this was
in preparation for Bridget Jones yeah
how long how long did you do it for ah
let's see I went over in January we
started filming after Easter
so come on yeah good good few months
yeah so I mean you must have done
something well yeah I did I got the
coffee I made the coffee I had to you
know cut anything out of you know the
local periodicals or that are about the
authors that the publishing company
represented so I do that and then follow
them away and I had to organize the the
book launches and things like that
yeah well and who do they say you were
they said that I was a Bridget Cavendish
so a relative of the gentleman who was
the owner of the publishers which
explained why I got the job with
absolutely no skills whatsoever
[Music]